man a regional leader in Spain was to
break away and form a new country he's
under growing pressure this morning not
to separate Catalonia from Spain huge
rallies yesterday condemn the regional
governments bout to declare independence
after disputed referendum Seth Doane is
in Barcelona the capital of Catalonia in
northeastern Spain he's in front of the
Catalonian president's office south good
morning good morning to you this is a
political cliffhanger on one side you
have the leader of Catalonia who's is
expected to declare independence on the
other side you have Spain's prime
minister who has said he vows to not let
that happen and in the middle on the
streets you have both sides digging in
calling themselves the silent majority
hundreds of thousands of protesters were
hardly silent on Sunday chanting for a
united Spain people and the crowd here
are telling us that these were the
voices that were not heard in last
week's referendum on October 1st 43% of
eligible voters in Catalonia turned out
to the polls despite the central
government's efforts to stop them
police smashed into polling stations to
remove ballot boxes and voters
themselves did you vote in the
referendum
many boycotted the regional referendum
because they saw it as illegal but 90%
of those who did cast ballots voted in
favor of splitting from Spain this
relatively rich region says it
contributes more to Madrid than it gets
in return and many here think they'd be
better off on their own is not a matter
of having a passport professor John
Lopez has counseled catalonia's
government on becoming independent in
the new republic we think that we are
going to live in a better country and
that improves every dimension of life
from the public health to the public
schools Catalonia has been supportive
part of Spain since the 15th century but
it has its own language its own culture
its own tradition its own food will it
have its own country stay tuned
fionna yeah it's a story many in the EU
are following closely Seth Doane in
Barcelona thank you so much